Giant cardboard robot arms, and eyelashes
for your car.
It's episode 14 of Lüt.
This optical mouse transforms into a mechanical
beast that can battle your pig-shaped desk
vacuum.
Be sure to team it up with this USB flashdrive.
And here's a Chinese farmer who grows pears
inside molds so they wind up looking like
little, edible Buddhas.
This ax appears to be going through your wall,
but, actually, it's just perfect for hanging
up keys or a coat.
While you're out in the sun this summer, be
sure to wear your solar powered bikini that
can charge your phone and iPod.
Or, to be more formal, use these power icon
cufflinks with built-in LED's that breath
like a sleeping computer.
If you go to a summer BBQ, blend in by wearing
Que, a cologne that smells like spices, smoke,
meat, and sweet summer sweat.
And be sure to bring your host a bottle of
wine topped with the Daddy Wine Puzzle: an
infuriatingly difficult puzzle to open that
locks the bottle's cork.
Well, why eat boring hot dogs when you could
have a Happy Hot Dog Man?
This one-move slicer gives your tube-meat
limbs and a face that you can decorate.
Is that too happy?
Well, roast your weenies with the Cthulhu
Skull Roaster instead.
Oh, and don't forget corn, which is much more
funner as a Lightsaber corn cup.
Get classy by tossing your summer salad in
this bowl that resembles a boat with oars,
and, of course, if you insist on eating clean
food, you should stick with this hot dog.
It's actually an artfully colored and molded
bar of soap.
Finally, serve Vat 19's Unfortunate Cookies.
Once the food coma sets in, blow up your necktie
like a balloon, and sleep on it like a pillow.
These mugs from Neatorama give you a fun animal
nose when you drink out of them, but if you
think that's all just a bunch of monkey business,
grab this mug with a built-in motor that stirs
itself.
As you wait, add Jesus to your morning waffles.
Your breakfast, I'm sure, followed a glorious
night's rest on your girlfriend's lap-shaped
pillow.
Or, your Boyfriend Arm Pillow that hugs you
when no one else is around.
If you're a newborn baby watching the program,
be sure to check out the Zaky: disembodied
hand-pillows that cradle you...
Want to be weirder?
Well, take a nap at the office inside the
Ostrich: A sensory depravation sleeping sack
you sling over your shoulder like a soft,
luxurious bladder.
Now, something free: Instructions from Instructables
on how to turn your old, boring appliances
into a VHS toaster.
And, as always, thanks for watching.